resident alien aeration
and four frozen sodas just exploded in
my truck well that's on you for keeping
soda in your truck
if you kept popping your truck then
you'd know it was going to pop open
duh fishing so this is dr by the lake
everybody was talking about
yep and this is the part of the show
where we wonder what the two of you have
been talking about on the drive over to
the lake
i mean thanks for getting us up to speed
but all the talk about the person you're
going to meet maybe should have happened
before you pulled up to
you know meet him what'd he do out here
files complaints against the police
department for looking through private
property where's your warrant
i'm not sure why harry would risk
remaining in his true form while
strangers walk closer and closer
it's only by the grace of plot that
neither officer sees the alien hands
but they could have they were right
there
this alien race is supposed to be way
more advanced than humans however their
spacecraft can't prevent damage from a
lightning strike
airplanes made by humans can withstand
all kinds of lightning strikes how would
this craft even make it through space
there are all kinds of charged particles
that would do way more damage than
lightning
[Music]
while everyone watches the murder unfold
with wide-eyed wonder i'm going to spend
the remainder of this episode wondering
how a stiff breeze managed to fling open
the doors to this cabin so easily he
lives in a frozen wasteland there is
no way this is proper insulation
planning maybe harry the human deserved
to die
i told you fidget spinners were evil
and now i've seen the intricacies of an
alien pelvis neat
i mean it's sort of impressive that the
alien transformed into a naked human
you know considering the individual that
was just murdered was wearing clothing
and left all the naked parts up to the
imagination
one of the most unbelievable things
about this episode is that the alien
managed to somehow reconstruct the
obliterated french doors on its own
i got news for you i've got news
for you cassette i got news for you
cozette
if alien harry is supposed to be
practicing mimicry here he's doing a
somewhat terrible job lenny briscoe is
clearly saying
i got news for you cozette and alien
harry is repeating it as i've got news
for you cozette
it's a contraction of lies when my ship
crashed i lost precious cargo
a device i need to complete my mission
so the ship had no shields to protect it
from lightning and no gps tracker for
the super important mission completing
device
superior race indeed
[Applause]
kids and the internet said that parking
was a nightmare but yet here you park
with no issue at all
which can't be true because the internet
never lies also
excuse me the alien has an internet
connection in the middle of
nowhere i have to remove my shoes raise
my right hand touch the light fixture
and pray for a strong enough connection
to find a chimichanga recipe that's just
not fair
also also if this is his first time to
town or did he get a smartphone to
access the internet to learn these
things
the cabin appeared to be antiquated with
an old tv and radio
so how did he buy a smartphone and have
it delivered
smelling someone without explicit
consent i was sleeping uh
she's not the dead doctor he's over
there
but she is the sort of person that can
take a nap in the same room with the
dead body of her comrade
and that tv sins friends is a
sin a grief counselor is coming to speak
to each and every one of us
oh yeah good job snowflake is that
coming out of the town budget or is he
working for hugs
making fun of therapy when you should
most likely be in it yourself cliche
as someone who has learned life lessons
by watching law and order reruns
alien harry should know he needs to be
wearing gloves when he removes the sheet
i was making a joke i'm a very funny
person
i am really enjoying allen's aloof alien
performance so much
but i'm confused about how the alien
would lack an understanding of basic
interactions like
laughing or handshakes he has access to
the internet but also only understands
appropriate exchanges based on a crime
procedural episode on repeat
that means there are more people in this
town who can see me as an
alien than there are slices of pizza but
just because there isn't a pizza place
doesn't mean there isn't pizza grocery
stores and gas stations exist here and
since alien harry is all about the
research
he should know this sam hodges has been
my doctor since i was a kid and i'm not
going anywhere until i know what
happened to him which means you are way
too close to the case and should not be
anywhere near it
haley might be a dick but he's a dick
that's correct this autopsy's on for
some time i
appreciate you helping us you you did a
good job
and we aren't supposed to question that
at all we just accept that because the
alien says he's smart that it means he's
also capable of being skilled enough to
perform a
autopsy without tipping off his lack of
experience to the trained professionals
around him
i guess he did repair the french doors
so maybe this is all plausible
i'm gonna go across the street to the 59
to get a drink if you want to come
why would austin invite a man for drinks
when he compared her to a lizard and
creepily complimented her skin tone sure
we find out she wants to use him for his
truck but there are no other options
surely someone has a truck that doesn't
say like i like your brown skin
like a bozo this is when you're supposed
to ask me about my childhood
why i don't care holy finally a skip
moment built right into the show
i honor you resident alien i honor you i
left home when i was 16.
jiminy criminy lady why are you talking
about anything to do with your life when
harry doesn't care and neither do you
i'm convinced that she is far scarier
than murder hobo harry
maybe stick around long enough to find
out what it means i'd give all the sins
back if the alien decided that he
couldn't leave town because the mystery
of the 59 was so compelling he had to
wait until the bartender finally
revealed the full story to him
imagine it two full seasons later and
they'd finally say 59 died to save one
and then the alien just rage murders
everyone because he waited so long to
learn
nothing interesting repeatedly and
purposely disrespecting your liver
or whatever the alien equivalent of the
liver would be
thinking nicki minaj's starships would
get an entire bar on their feet in 2021
the answer's simple it's nighttime i'll
just break into that kid's house and
kill it
this side plot may be funny enough that
we're about to give a send back for a
moment involving the contemplation of a
child's demise
and you say you've never seen miracles
in the real world however with that
being said i can't let it go that allen
is able to find the kid so easily i
suppose because this town's only about a
thousand people we're supposed to
pretend the alien could actually
find the kid's house while drunk when in
fact that is obviously bullsh
even if the window only goes up so far
who leaves their child's ground floor
bedroom window unlocked at night
and don't give me the small town excuse
lock your windows people
especially your children's turns out
that this scene is supposed to be pretty
scary but because you can see
nothing it's no big deal i'm gonna give
you the count of three get down
no there's nothing under the bed
parenting
[Music]
6 a.m whiskey headache
nausea severe dehydration excitement
alcohol must not affect humans the way
it does us alien harry can quote law and
order episodes and neil armstrong he
knows how to check the internet and not
to mention performing
autopsy but he doesn't know how alcohol
works he should [ __ ] know how
alcohol works
not knowing how to solve the trolley
problem
his beatbox rendition of amazing grace
is way better than what she was trying
to listen to on the radio so the sin as
always
is radio yeah you're getting that
twitching aren't you down in your tank
you know why that's your body's way of
telling you you're guilty
good news everyone that tightening cold
feeling of evil tendrils wrapping around
my heart is apparently not a sign of me
being a guilty [ __ ] on the sure path
to hell because guilt is apparently
located in my taint which hasn't
twitched since october 27th 2004
actual footage of the sims team doing
inappropriate research for scripts
somehow makes its way into the episode
what are you doing home well i needed to
make sure i was conveniently here when
you're picking up your stuff and had
another guy with you so i could pull
some alpha bull
and set up a scenario where you would
see that harry's not like other humans
does that about cover it
i needed his truck for two boxes and a
guitar pretty sure a car could have
easily taken care of these items hell a
scooter or bike could also work if you
have the bungee cords in an imagination
of course she's in danger the guy had a
skull on his arm with a snake coming out
of its eye socket
judging a person based on their ink i
mean he's right the guy is dangerous but
maybe his attitude and quickness to
display a gun was more accurate proof to
that fact than body art
walking barefoot in the snow do you want
to get frostbite asta
because this is how you get ants that
have frostbite because they got trapped
between your toes
before you walked barefoot in the snow
i've always been an outsider essie
hinton's resident alien
his windpipe he needed air he tried to
give himself a tracheotomy
and you had to reopen the casket to
confirm this go test the organs everyone
who watches crime shows knows this
because sam hodges was poisoned and one
of the people here
is the murderer
in just one episode alien harry has
clunk-lunged his way into a classic
character
we're taking a sin back reverse clunk
clung style
ah yes i've not had enough of asta's
terrible and abusive husband
so glad the show decided to go back to
that scenario for a bit
hooray
tunnel vision
yeah alien harry would be
extraterrestrial at tv sins
oh boys i'm back
yeah i'm sheriff mike thompson they call
me
mr tibbs
i am smarter than you what are you 12 ah
as f now i have to meet her over there
and prove to her i fit in
really important in this pose that you
arch your back and keep it flat
at the same time
it smells like fish in here donnie was a
good bowler
and a good man he was he was one of us